Ein amerikanisches forschungsteam hat eine wirklich unglaubliche künstliche intelligenz entwickelt sie kam tatsächlich den wahrscheinlichsten
todeszeitpunkt eines patienten oder einer patientin voraussagen und sie funktioniert wirklich ob glücklicherweise oder bedauerlicherweise
Naja, jetzt gibt's für sein pilotprojekt sie wird in einem krankenhaus
Getestet wie die ki
Genau funktioniert und warum sie damit das sterben sogar so angenehm wie möglich macht jetzt den klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Um no
Angenehmes sterben durch eine künstliche intelligenz ki die meinen tod voraus sagt, höra
Also von anfang an wir haben ja hier schon öfter über die planning modelle berichtet eine form der künstlichen intelligenz die in der lage ist
riesige datenmengen zu analysieren und daraus
eigenständig zu lernen bei dieser
konkreten ki datenanalyse technik haben die wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler neuronaler netzwerke darauf hin trainiert den wahrscheinlichsten
todeszeitpunkt einer patientin oder eines patienten vorauszusagen und
konkret die frage zu beantworten ob eine patientin oder ein patient innerhalb der nächsten drei bis zwölf monate sterben wird die
prognose erfolgt innerhalb von 24 stunden nach der einweisung in ein krankenhaus das training der ki basierte auf
hunderttausenden patientendaten konkret wurden die algorithmen mit daten aus 19 jahren und insgesamt mit mehr als
21.000 patientenakten gefüttert an der entwicklung der künstlichen intelligenz beteiligt waren übrigens
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler aus dem medizinischen bereich und
Der informatik mit hilfe des programms python eignete sich die ki also eigenständig an innerhalb von 24 stunden nach aufnahme
einen
wahrscheinlichsten
todeszeitpunkt zu
prognostizieren und das anhand der patientendaten und
Das ergebnis der ki war wirklich ziemlich krass in neun von zehn fällen hatte sie den todeszeitpunkt
innerhalb der vorgegebenen zeitspanne
richtig vorhergesagt und auch in
gegensätzlichen verlag.de oft richtig in 95 prozent der fälle bei denen die ki vorausgesagt
hatte dass die sterbewahrscheinlichkeit eher gering war lebten diese tatsächlich noch länger als ein jahr weiter aber wofür das ganze
Vielleicht macht es ja sinn wenn ihr die wahl hätte tvo
Und wie würdet ihr dann die letzten stunden ihres lebens verbringen wollen die antwort hängt sicherlich
Davon ab unter welchen umständen das möglich ist ob gesund oder eben krank
für den großteil der menschen die unheilbar krank sind steht jedenfalls fest dass sie nicht
im krankenhaus
darauf warten wollen dass sie sterben in den usa beispielsweise gibt es studien nach denen 80 prozent
der menschen ihre letzte lebenszeit
Zu hause wollen in ihrem gewohnten umfeld und mit den menschen um sich die ihnen wichtig sind das schlimme an der realität aber ist
dass sich 60 prozent der todesfälle solcher patienten auf der intensivstation
eines krankenhauses
zeiten also genau das was sich todkranke menschen eben nicht wünschen der grund dafür liegt den studien zufolge meistens an einer fehleinschätzung
der ärztinnen und ärzte die behandeln und die die patienten nicht
Rechtzeitig in die palliative versorgung also die versorgung vor dem tod übergeben und genau dieses problem
Ist das forschungsteam der stanford university angegangen und hat dafür die künstliche intelligenz
Entwickelt diese kann jetzt ermöglichen das todkranke patienten die möglichkeit bekommen ihre letzten tage zu hause verbringen zu können
und zudem
Palliativ versorgt zu werden diesen bereich der medizin geht es ja nicht darum die todkranken patienten so lange wie möglich
am leben
zu halten sondern ihnen stattdessen dem tod so
Angenehm wie möglich zu machen für die studie von großer bedeutung waren vor allem todkranke menschen die drei bis zwölf monate nach ihrer aufnahme
verstorben denn sie sind die besten kandidatinnen und kandidaten für die
palliativmedizin das forschungsteam suchte aus denjenigen ergebnisse der ki bei denen sie sich
Am sichersten waren zufällig 50 patientinnen und patienten aus ihre daten wurden dann von
spezialisten aus den palliativen bereich bewertet und zwar dahingehend ob diese tatsächlich für die palliative versorgung in frage gekommen wären und
Die ergebnisse waren eben wie beschrieben absolut positiv die künstliche intelligenz wird deswegen jetzt auch als
pilotprojekt
Am uniklinikum in stanford eingesetzt und auch dort soll sie patientinnen und patienten
identifizieren für die eine palliative versorgung also eben die vor dem tod angesagt wäre eine wirklich gute sache die zukünftig tatsächlich die
gesundheitsvorsorge in großem stil verbessern könnte doch dafür musik
weiter lernen denn bislang passiert ihr wissen nur auf den patientendaten aus zwei krankenhäusern
Doch auch schon diese kann mit diesen wenigen daten schafft es dass die lebensqualität und das wohlbefinden von todkranken menschen
deutlich verbessert hat bislang stehen in vielen fällen tatsächlich weitere medizinische behandlungen auf dem programm die von den patientinnen passiert
selbst aber eher als
Belastend empfunden werden und auch überhaupt keinen sinn machen wenn ihr als erstes neues zum thema karin zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann meldet
euch hierbei whatsapp an dann erfahrt ihr vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt in der redaktion von kriegs- und mitmachen und themen vorschlagen oder fragen zu videos stellen
Der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das aber mit glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
krieg gegen künstliche intelligenz hacker planen widerstand ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran